anybody not using
a database automation tool currently
everybody's got automated database
deployments
it's okay it's a safe place
partially
okay
still got somebody you know clicking the
button perhaps
cool
any other questions people have or
things they want to talk about
yeah
something better than migrations uh-oh
what's that document
document database
anybody else got anything that they want
to talk about
so what tools are you guys using today
those of you who have uh database
automation
any framework
anybody else got anything else beside
ddf
sql scripts
cool
liquid base okay cool
is anybody here use flyway by chance
handful cool we'll be doing a live demo
of flyway so hopefully the demo gods are
are with me today and the internet
but if not we do have a recording so
that's worst case scenario
all right so it's 10 20 so i'm just
going to go ahead and get started uh
welcome everybody my name is scott and
today i'm going to be talking to you
about devops for databases i have
already posted these slides up on my
blog which is uh my first and last name
scottsdale.com and you can follow me on
twitter
um just scott's over there as well
so before we get started i just want to
kind of level set on what we're going to
be talking about today that way you know
if this isn't kind of what you're
expecting you can go check out another
ndc talk you won't hurt my feelings or
anything like that
so we're really trying to target
developers or dbas who want to automate
their database deployments because i
find a lot of companies and we'll talk
about
the statistics on that a little bit
later
don't have any database automation
at their companies or
you know sometimes people just don't
really know where to get started they
might have a little bit of automation
but then you know they're still stuck
doing some manual steps
so just a quick pull like how many
developers do we have in the room
okay like three fours eighty percent of
the room how many dbas do we have
one
okay it's not shame the dpa in the room
uh any managers
handful okay cool and everybody else you
know maybe you partied a little too hard
last night so you don't want to raise
your hand that's totally fine
so we're gonna talk about all these
different uh topics today we're gonna
talk about what choices you need to make
what are the trade-offs of the different
options like we talked about
migration-based approaches and we'll
talk about model-based approaches as
well
what tools are out there what challenges
you will face both technical and
political slash organizational and i'll
do a live demo
using flyway and github actions here in
a little bit along with docker
and i'll take questions at the end
so my goals for you in this talk is just
ramp up on how to implement automation
to your databases using the various
technologies we've kind of touched on
and know the options and trade-offs for
all the different approaches and tools
that you have at your disposal
so who am i i'm the director of
engineering at a software consulting
company called lean techniques
as you can probably tell by my accent
i'm from the u.s
we're based in des moines iowa which is
kind of the center
of the u.s
i'm also the co-organizer of the
iowa.net user group i've automated
dozens of databases now i'm friend of
redgate and i blog as well
all right let's dive in
so
i've worked with
fortune 100 companies all the way down
to startups and being in consulting and
i typically see three main manual
workflows when people have database
changes
the first one is the developers write
review and deploy the sql all themselves
second one is the developers read the
sql but then hand it off to a dba
perhaps
to review and then deploy the sql
or the third one
and i see this one less often but uh
developers tell dbas what they want then
the dbas write review and then deploy
the sequel just curious a show of hands
how many people have dbas in their
organization
all right maybe like a third of the room
okay cool
so what's a manual workflow look like
today
uh it's usually one of two things i
usually either see like what i call the
compare approach where you do a bunch of
development on your database and then
you use a tool like sql compare or pg
admin to compare the changes that you've
made to create a sql script for you
essentially and you take that sql script
and deploy it to prod however you do
that today
or there's what i call the gather sql
scripts approach where you accumulate
all these sql scripts and then you know
hand it off to somebody
like maybe a team lead or maybe you have
access to production and eventually you
run those scripts against production
so what's wrong with these manual
approaches well the first thing is you
don't have any source control you have
no traceability of who did what when did
they do it how did they do it you've got
none of that because everything is
manual
and manual obviously leads itself to
being really tedious like how many
people have deployed a sql script
manually before
most of the room keep your hand up if
that was your favorite part of your job
nobody right like nobody actually likes
manually deploying stuff
and it's easy for somebody to make
mistakes like uh how many people have
ran a sql script against the wrong
environment before
yep
a lot of people
who previously had their hand up put
their hand up again and everybody else
who kept their hand down is probably a
liar but that's okay
uh as well as this script order can get
out of whack because you might have like
a create table and then an alter table
script and you might run one of those
out of order so that's another issue
with manual deployments is that script
order can totally get out of whack
as well as
your development database that you're
working against in your production
database could be out of sync so how
many people have to deal with stored
procedures or views or functions or
things like that
probably half the room right
so those of you who have dealt with
those things know that the last one in
wins right so if you're making a change
to a store procedure review or function
or any of those types of things
if you don't have the latest changes in
your development environment you could
potentially be overriding somebody
else's changes so there's no forced
continuous integration where you're
continuously integrating your changes
with other people's changes
all right so that's kind of like level
setting like what's the problem with
manual uh
database deployments so let's talk about
what devops is here real quick
so this is probably my favorite
definition of what devops is it's by
donovan brown from microsoft he said
devops is the union of people process
and products to enable continuous
delivery of value to our end users
i just want to focus on two different
sections here this first section talking
about people process and products
so if you don't have people bought into
a devops mindset
you will struggle implementing like
devops pipelines throughout your
organization
and then you also need the process so
you need to know what all needs to
happen in order for us to deploy
something to production
and then finally the easiest part
honestly is the tools the products the
things that actually do the automation
that is honestly the easiest part of
these of these three um because the
tools uh you know are proven over time
and when you've got some cultural things
going on that can be a bit of a
challenge
as well as i like to focus on this part
too value to our end users right
like the only reason why any of us in
this room have a job and are here today
is because presumably we're adding value
to our end users right and that's
something i like to focus on when you're
dealing with some of these
organizational challenges
is at the end of the day what we're
trying to get out of this is value to
our end users to deliver our software
more frequently and more reliably
and i also like this quote by julie
gunderson she said you can't change
culture and process with a credit card
you can't go to microsoft or google or
anything like that and say hello i'd
like one devops please
and it just kind of works right
you have to get your culture and your
process uh bought into devops so you
don't have people bypassing the pipeline
going directly to production anything
like that we'll talk a little bit
more about that later
all right so how do we apply devops to
databases
so i have these in order of importance
not necessarily the order in which
you'll run things but first off get your
database source controlled so if you
don't have your database in source
control just
uh extract out all your ddl drop it into
a source control and that's like the
very first step that you can
do second most important thing is make
database deployments at most a single
click of a single button
i have a bit of an extreme take that i
would rather just deploy straight to
production assuming you have
uh automated tests in place that give
you that feedback that confidence at
everything screen because at the end of
the day if your ci pipeline is green and
you're not deploying production that
means you've got a confidence gap right
and we need to fill that confidence gap
and usually what i find is that
confidence gap can be filled with
automated tests so that when when you're
green and when you're when your ci
pipeline is green
you should be confident to be able to
deploy all the way out to production
but at most database deployments should
be a single click of a single button
and then you also want database builds
to verify each commit so you want to
test out your migrations and make sure
that everything's good to go as well
all right
so redgate runs a survey called the
state of database devops survey and this
is from 2021
so i'll have you look at those numbers
here real quick so we're going to talk
about a few of these
so first one we're going to talk about
is version control
so if you notice the red bar is uh for
databases or for applications and the
black bars are for
databases
so for version control 85 of
applications have source control
i just want to pause there for a second
like does that terrify anybody else that
15 of applications out there aren't even
in source control
like when i saw this i'm like that has
to be wrong but
it wasn't so anyway tangent
back to databases
uh so you can see databases that are
lagging behind
applications at 62
now i will say
keep in mind this is a survey put on by
redgate
redgate makes tools for databases right
so i would honestly take these numbers
and cut them all in half because
the people responding to this survey
probably are more likely to have
database automation than
you know you're just average company and
i would say
uh 80 of the companies i talk to
don't have
database automation in place
at all and then most of them don't have
database automation across their entire
application suite
so that's one area that we're going to
be talking about is version control
another one we're going to be talking
about is automated builds so 64 of
applications have automated builds
compared to 36 percent of databases
again slice that in half i'd probably
say 18
of database databases have automated
builds
and then the last part 41 of
applications uh have automated
deployments
and 28
of databases have automated deployments
again slice that in half probably more
like 14
so why is this hard
like for those of you who don't have
this across the board like why why don't
you have this across the board what
makes databases so so much harder than
applications
but traditionally the tools are not
there to do it
right the main reason and also
dbas
are very
have a different mindset to developers
you've got this
you know split between the developers
and the dbas
and
uh the dpas want scripts
in their traditional format
and um
you know you're kind of in a way maybe
doing them out of a job as well they're
very conservative very risk-averse don't
like new stuff
yep those are the main reasons
so there's i just want to summarize for
people who can hear uh
there's a few things there uh tool
tooling you know is in first class
citizen uh for databases oftentimes uh
and then dbas uh you know they have a
different way of working than developers
uh they might feel like they're getting
cut out of the process
is that good summary yeah okay yep uh
values in the data you screw up the data
you've lost all the value yep values in
the data if you screw up the data you've
lost all the value absolutely
more of a reason to
keep it in source control
scary
yep
absolutely
at the end of the day
you have as many nightmares trying to
upgrade your fire uploading
routines and stuff as well yep yeah if
you uh mess up your data you're in a bad
bad spot for sure
yeah
quick fixes
yep so getting hotfixes out or faster
just going directly to production versus
having a pipeline yep
yeah
um
so when you're saying version mismatches
are you talking about like the database
engine itself like what version of sql
server you're running on or okay
yep
yeah i think one of the big reasons is
also that development teams actually
spend a long time organizing their work
with scrum or whatever trying to get
more efficient all the time and at least
my experience from the financial sector
where we are sort of separated
developers are separate from the
production environments and dbas are
typically in the production environment
part of the organization and they don't
do these things
they are not continuously improving as a
way of life yep so there's a rift
between developers and dbas separate
teams and they just work differently
yeah
you know database indexes and i don't
know
uh
provisioning disks and all this
version controls are not on their radar
yep yeah version control is definitely
not
first thought for data
[Laughter]
nice and developers hate to do the same
thing
twice
and ebay loves to do the same thing
yeah
so i had a lot of the same reasons you
guys did um so
as we talked about you know on the
previous slide you know 72 percent of
companies don't have
automated builds and deploys because
only 28 according to the survey had
automated deploys
and again i would probably say that's
that's light
so as we kind of talked about source
control is not traditionally built into
database tools like sql server
management studio pg admin data group
some of those it's not traditionally
been a first-class citizen like it is in
you know application ids like visual
studio visual studio code writer
webstorm all those
as well as how many people have dealt
with link
servers all right keep your hand up if
you like link servers
one person likes link servers all right
we won't haze you too bad then
uh as well as people do things like
database hopping right where you hop
from like one database to the other and
like query across multiple databases
those things can also be challenging
when you're implementing a database
devops pipeline
and as we kind of touched on earlier
like this requires devs and dbas to come
to some sort of agreement right and talk
to each other and you know our industry
isn't exactly known for communication
and collaboration uh
and
knocking that out of the park
as well as you know we talked about this
too
dbas think that they're getting cut out
but spoiler they're not right like we
talked about earlier how many people
actually like running sql scripts over
and over and over again like that's i've
talked a lot of dbas that is not their
favorite part of their job it's
performance tuning index adding indexes
uh designing database warehouses like
all that kind of stuff
it's not running sql scripts over and
over and over again so we're actually
freeing dbas up to do more of what they
like to do and adding more value to the
organization than you know being the
gatekeepers
of the sql scripts
some other reasons like we talked about
the database is stateful uh whereas
applications are not or at least
shouldn't be right
so if you need to roll back an
application right like largely the
process conceptually is blow away all
these files and then replace them with
the old ones right
whereas if you need to roll back a
database like everything requires a
little bit of thought right like what
exactly what exact change did you make
did you you know add a new column okay
did anybody add data to that column that
you need to keep track of
uh that you want to draw
after after you drop the column or
whatever the case may be like
everything's super contextual based on
what that script was doing
and i will say it's a lot easier on
greenfield databases um so if you're
starting a brand new database
just start with database automation from
the very very get-go like don't uh you
know try and backport it later just
start from the very beginning with
database automation
because that just gets a lot easier
versus when you're trying to backport it
to
databases like i've dealt with
multi-tenant databases where there's
like hundreds of customers with the same
database
schema in each and there's even drift
between
the different customers
databases and some of it was intentional
if we have time i can dive into some of
those stories a little bit later
but
just from the very beginning start with
database automation don't put that aside
all right
it's been let's start
talking about how we apply
the devops to databases so what do we
want to source control we want to put
the table views stored procedures any
ddl put that schema into source control
as well as any static data this is
something that some people don't think
about is
any data that's needed for that
application to run successfully things
like lookup data like configuration if
you've got feature toggles in a database
whatever roles
any lookup table data get that stuff
into source control as well
so how do you do this we talked a little
bit earlier about
migration-based approaches and there's
also a concept of model based approaches
as well
so the model-based approach is basically
like hey here's my ideal state of the
database the table should look like this
these stored procedures should look like
this all that kind of stuff
and then basically the tool just figures
out okay i need to
make that production database look like
that ideal model so some examples of
tools that do this redgate sql source
control microsoft backpack
uh i don't prefer this approach
and the reason is you just lack a little
bit of control
at the end of the day so think about
things like column renames
uh i've seen some of these tools
not be able to figure out what a uh how
to rename a column and do with something
like a drop in an ad which obviously is
not exactly what you wanted
more than likely uh and i would say this
approach is losing mindshare too
to
migration-based approaches
so this is where every change that you
have is scripted
and then those scripts are committed to
source control and they're run in a very
particular order so i've seen
scripts be like date based i've seen
them be
like just number version based as well
and so you know you need to run these
scripts in a very particular order so
your create tables
happen before your alter tables oops
and uh which scripts i've been running
are then kept track of in some sort of
table so we talked about any framework a
little bit earlier and a d framework has
the i think it's like underscore
underscore ef migrations history table
a lot of these tools have
the exact same thing or the exact same
concept
and this requires you to write them up
front during development and then run
those exact same scripts in every single
environment so whatever environments you
have between your local machine and
production you run those exact same
scripts throughout all of those
environments
so some examples of tools uh flyway
uh is a good tool and we'll demo that
here in a little bit it's a little bit
more cross platform
or a platform agnostic whether you're
writing like you know c sharp java
javascript or whatever the case may be
if you're in netland any framework
migrations db up and roundhouse are also
all good options
as somebody mentioned liquor base
earlier that's also another good option
as well
and migration based is my preferred
approach um over the model based
approach
so how do we source control the database
so this is where my opinions start to
come in and you might disagree with them
and that's totally okay
but in my opinion if the database is
only meant for one uh application
i want that database code and
application code to live together in the
same repository this is assuming you
don't have like a shared database shared
across tons of different applications
right so if you're in that more uh more
monolithic database scenario i might uh
lean towards ripping it out into its own
separate repository
but if you have it all in the same
repository then you can look at one pull
request one commit
for the application code and the sql
code so you can see like okay i added
this column uh you know it's in my
c-sharp models you know and that's this
cascades down in this way you can see
that all in one single pane of glass
versus versus having it in multiple
repos and having to stitch that
information together
and ideally the final schema and the
migrations live together as well so you
with migrations you kind of just see the
deltas and the changes and ideally if
you can get the final schema in there so
you can kind of see what everything
looks like
that would also be ideal
all right so now we're going to talk
about automated builds
so responsibilities of automated build
is to take those migrations and deploy
them to some independent database
whether you have
uh you're spinning up a database on the
fly with something like docker which
we'll demo here in a little bit or you
have a
database dedicated to ci so this is
trying to tell you whether or not your
migrations are even valid
you use some sort of build tool such as
github actions azure devops jenkins team
city circle ci
there's tons of different build tools
out there that you can use
all right automated deployments how do
we do those
responsibilities of an automated
deployment is to take those migrations
and deploy them to each environment
and the automated deployment step also
swaps out any secrets so things like
connection strings uh so that way you're
not
uh you know storing those connection
strings and source control you have them
you know in your pipeline swapping in
and out
you can use the deployment tool for that
uh things like octopus deploy github
actions azure devops jenkins teamcity
the list goes on and on
all right
so if you aren't doing this today and
let's say you have dbas in the mix i'm
going to propose a workflow as like a
starting point and then you can add and
remove things as what makes sense for
your organization
so the developer adds the application
code and sql code because they have the
most context on what it is that they
need
developer commits that are branch and
sends a pull request for a code review
another developer reviews the
application code possibly a dba gets
involved here if you have dbas reviewing
the sql code if you're on things like
github they have like the code owner's
file saying hey anything in this folder
needs to get reviewed by this person so
that's how you or this group of people
so that's how you can get the dbas
involved
uh when both are approved that code's
merged into the main branch
that code is then built independently to
verify that the commit that they just
created was valid
and then deployments are at most again a
single button push
all right we're going to test out the
conference wi-fi here and see how things
go
so
i am going to demo a
fly away using github actions and also
primarily interacting with flyway using
docker so
i guess the level set real quick flyway
is just a cli tool so you just
if you want you can download it um and
install it and you just run flyway and
then there's a few different commands
i am oops i am going to be executing
those via docker
um so in this docker compose file i just
have the database which i'm just using
postgres here
my database is called a site to order
stuff because i'm really
creative and didn't know what to call it
and then i'm suffixing the environment
there
and then i've got oops
the flyway image um so this pre-installs
the
flyaway cli for me so that way i don't
have to install it on my machine so you
guys can pull this down if you just go
to github.com
my first last name scott sauber and
slash database devops and i'll have a
link at the end too
you can pull this down and run it as
long as you have docker everything
should be good to go
so this this flyway image has flyway
pre-installed and at the end of the day
we're calling flyway migrate
but then you can pass fly away a bunch
of different options so
in this case i guess i should ask can
everybody see that okay
everybody in the back good all right
awesome
so we're giving it a connection string
here and telling it hey you know here's
the database to connect to here's the
username and password and then we're
running migrate at the end of the day
so what migrate does is
this is looking for a folder called sql
and then i just separated these by
repeatable inversion and we'll talk
about those here in a second
but what a version migration is is this
is something that you only want to run
once right so
with flyway how you tell something is
versioned is you do v and then you give
it a number and then do two underscores
and then you can give it whatever name
you want so i call this create
underscore customers underscore table
dot sql
and so these are version migrations run
in a very particular order so i'll have
like v1 then v2 and then v3 or you can
do like v 1.1 or whatever the case may
be it'll just run on that very
particular order and then it'll write to
a
flyway underscore schema underscore
history table and we'll take a look at
that here in a second
but then flyway also has the concepts of
repeatable migrations so first flywheel
will run all the version migrations and
then it will run repeatable migrations
and so repeatable migrations are good
things are good for things like views or
procedures functions things that you can
run over and over and over again
and those run after you run
the version migrations
all right so i'm going to go ahead and
crack open
cli here can everybody see that
hopefully
good to go all right so i'm just gonna
run docker compose up
and so what this will do is it will so
if you want to pull this down oops i
actually don't want to echo out all of
the logs and run this in detach mode so
what this will do is it will
spin up my
db database here the postgres database
and then it will spin up flyway and
execute those migrations
against flyway so if i come over here
and look at the logs
oh sorry i need to docker compose
i'm not sure why those logs haven't
shown up yet
i'm just gonna restart this do docker
compose down bring everything back down
and then
run this again
so i should see
some flyaway logs here
okay i'm not sure what happened right
there but um so this is my postgres
database standing up just telling me hey
i'm ready for connections and then this
is flyaway actually running here so you
can see
said hey i found two migrations uh i
didn't have a
schema flyway schema history table so i
went ahead and created that
and then i ran these two migrations and
i've successfully applied those
migrations
so if i come over here and look at
my database
so this one over here is the localhost
you can see i've got a customers table
here and if i look you've got the three
columns that i specified earlier
and if i look at the flywheel schema
history table here
you can see it's recording like hey you
know here's the migrations that ran
here's version one here's a description
which is just the name of the file with
spaces where the underscores were
here's the sql name
here's the checksum
so a nice feature is uh you can't ever
change a version migration after it's
been ran
so if i went into
uh one of these sql files and that i'd
already ran and tried to change it
flywood would yell at me and say hey you
already tried to change this right
so if i wanted to add another column for
instance i can't do that on my original
script i have to create a new script
that's doing like an alter table right
and that's just telling me hey who who
installed it when it was installed
execution time and all that good stuff
and then you can see here it's ran my
repeatable migration after the fact and
this is where the checksum for
repeatables is a little bit different
because anytime you change a repeatable
migration it will compare that checksum
that's in the database the checksum that
it generated based on the contents of
the file and rerun that file if that
checksum has changed so repeatables
don't run over and over and over again
they just run
uh anytime something changed
all right
so i'm going to create a new
uh migration here i'm going to add a new
column to the did uh to this customers
table as anybody have any ideas for a
column i could add
email all right
add
email column
and he was not a plant just to be clear
uh
that was a total random suggestion from
the audience i'm gonna say alter table
customers
add column
email
i'm going to say let's say somebody's
got a monstrous email and i'm just going
to say like a thousand right
uh
so i know did you know that apostrophes
are valid in emails how many people knew
that
a handful i didn't know that either and
uh
yeah apostrophes are valid in emails i
couldn't believe it anyway
um
so i'm going to go ahead and add this
email and i'm going to run
docker oops
docker compose up dash d
let that run here so my database is
already running and it's going to
reapply those migrations so if i go
ahead and run docker compose logs again
you can see it said hey i migrated this
i'm currently sorry i'm currently on
version 1 and i'm going to go ahead and
apply version 2 and so it added that
email column and it successfully applied
it but let's just go ahead and go verify
that
i'm going to refresh this here
and you can see
uh you know i've got a new column here
of email and you know it's got my var
varchar 1000 far car varchar heard it
both ways
um and if you go ahead and rerun this uh
the five-way schema history table you
notice i've got another uh versioned uh
record here as well
so let's go ahead and test the internet
for real now and see how this works
using github actions still connected to
the internet so that's good
i'm just going to go ahead and make a
branch called email and i'm going to say
add email column
so that'll do commit push and then
create me a new pull request
so you can see here
again the repo is just
my first and last name database devops
you can follow along if you want i've
got can everybody see that okay let me
bump that up a little bit it's good all
right
you can see here i've got the add column
email everything is good to go
but let's say i've got a dba involved
right and you can on this so that on
this other screen over here i am logged
in as me the dba right
and you can tell that because i'm not
using a dark background
so if i'm the dba here i might be like
uh
is a thousand characters really
necessary
right
and you can collaborate this way and
then come over here to my developer side
look at the conversation
maybe
oh i forgot to hit i didn't hit add
single
comment i hit create a review
alright so then you can see i'm saying
hey is 1000 characters really necessary
and i'm going to say yes because reasons
right
and as the developer and the dba as
totally reasonable unlike what somebody
said earlier and say oh okay that makes
sense
reasons totally make sense i'm going to
go ahead and say
approve this guy
and now as the developer i can go ahead
and squash and merge
and so i've got a database sitting out
in azure uh a single database server
that's got multiple databases on it just
single server just because i'm cheap
and it's got a development database and
a production database
so if we come over here to
flyway
or to github actions running flyway so
this is running flyway migrate again you
can go check out the source of source
code if you want this is just
pulling down docker and running uh
docker and applying flyway to my
development database is what this one is
and so you can see that it said hey i'm
currently on version one again the exact
same things we saw locally i'm migrating
to version two and i successfully
applied that as well
and i've got it to automatically deploy
to production assuming
development passes and so it's deploying
that out to production now as well
and everything is good to go you notice
it says pretty much the exact same thing
not pretty much the actual exact same
thing
something i forgot to
show
was
we also were running
this on the fly as well here in github
actions so
so on on the pull request i'm also
running a verify that's basically
running all my migrations in a docker
container
as well so you can see that
you know everything's good to go as well
so i get some extra validation that hey
everything's
good to go
so if i go over to my azure databases
so look at dev here first
and this is going to heartbeat back to
the us so this might take a hot second
but i went from three columns here
with the id first name last name to
need like some
music uh to now having an email for
development and then the exact same
thing for production as well
or if i refresh this again uh my email
will show up there as well
so this was kind of showing you like you
know taking those concepts that we
applied that we talked about earlier and
actually applying them by like you know
getting dbas involved using tools like
github
and using tools like flyaway as well so
flyway is really nice for things like
when you do have dbas involved or people
are more comfortable with sql uh if you
are coming from like a csharp.net
background uh i would probably lean
towards any framework migrations most of
the time it just kind of depends on your
scenario
also i would say flyway is good for
things like
you know if you've got store procedures
functions views those kinds of things
in your organization as well
all right
so that
yeah go for it it's your framework
migration good even if you're not using
entity formula
so the question was is any framework
migrations good even if you're not using
entity framework um
so it depends on so any framework
definitely has a c sharp lean to it so
if your developers aren't c-sharp
focused uh any framework probably
doesn't make too much sense but if they
are
you can absolutely use any framework
just for the migrations part of it
and not the orm part of it so
you can totally do that
if you so choose it's just you know if
you're if you're all in the entity
framework bought into the whole
ecosystem you get a little bit extra
benefits where you can run you know
migrations and integration tests and
things like that a little bit easier and
does ef framework work for
most databases like you use postgresql
in your example
because microsoft stuff tends to lean
towards sql server yep so the question
was uh does any framework work with
other database engines other than just
sql server um so i've used it with sql
server oracle
although i don't like to talk about my
oracle days
postgres and mysql as well and it's
worked on all those database engines
for me
cool
so some common gotcha is building the
database we kind of touched on this
earlier
you will pay for the
choices that were made
in your database so again things like
link servers cross database hopping
i've seen like people creating temp
tables and stored procedures also
causing issues as well
if you're not cleaning those up
and you know if you have old sore
procedures views functions that
reference old tables or columns that no
longer exist
those will have to
be cleared out as well because if you're
trying to build the whole database from
scratch
that will cause issues because database
engines don't like that
as well as we touched on multi-tenant
challenges earlier
if you have a multi-tenant environment
where each customer has their own
database you might run into challenges
there as well especially if all of those
databases aren't on the same schema so
you'll have to do some work
to sync those up
all right let's talk about rollbacks
so in my experience rollbacks are
usually not worth the headache
for a few reasons
like my first question of like you know
doing the one level higher thing of like
well why did
the
uh database migration work and like dev
uat qa whatever environments you have
before production
but didn't work in production and almost
always it's a failure in either people
or process where you know somebody might
have made a change directly to
production didn't cascade that down
or uh you know maybe you don't have in
your process you don't have like a good
test environment to test some of this
stuff out
um so that's like again the root cause
of like okay why do you even need
rollbacks in the first place
but then like let's say you're in the
situation where you're like you kind of
want to roll back
how do you roll back something that's
destructive right so if you have like a
drop or delete or truncate or something
like that
it's all contextual because it's kind of
like
hey uh you know if you're going to roll
back a
delete statement for instance okay i
need to pull that from a backup okay and
you know can you just migrate the data
over or you're gonna have to restore the
whole database okay are you gonna lose
lose your uh records and be too in
between the time when you
ran that migration and
uh you know when you're actually
executing this rollback so like
everything's super contextual so
uh so we talk about those trade-offs and
instead what i like to do is roll
forward so whatever uh change you need
to make to get things to work i would
just rather focus on rolling forward and
fixing the actual problem and not
actually worrying about rollbacks but
again it's very contextual sometimes
rollbacks
do make sense it's just that's not where
i go to first
so the other thing you'll run into is
people challenges because devops is a
mindset shift just like you know agile
is a mindset shift and you know things
like test driven development or mindset
shifts
so the more you can force nobody has
production right access the better
if people have production read access
that could make sense depending on your
company's scenarios but i really don't
like giving out production write access
or like alter tdl
permissions
because you can then force everything to
go through the pipeline you don't have
people bypassing the pipeline
uh so
this person i call danny the deployer
this is somebody i've seen in many
organizations when you don't have when
you don't force everything to go through
the pipeline if somebody still has those
keys to the kingdom
they might decide like hey you know i'm
not fully bought into this thing or you
know i have a hotfix that needs to go
out to production quick
i'm just going to go directly to prod
without source controlling it and i'll
i'll add it back later right
inevitably this usually almost always
causes pain
so
at the end of the day devs and dbas
again about i think like a third or half
the room had dbas in the organization
those two groups need to work together
and so
uh sometimes there's tension there right
so sometimes developers are like hey
dbas you know we heard some people talk
earlier dbas you know just cause
are the key the keys to the kingdom you
know uh they're just gatekeepers that
kinds of things meanwhile on the flip
side of it dbas are like hey developers
don't know how to properly design
databases right
and so that's where some of that tension
comes from so
some ways to cut through that tension is
again focus on the customer kind of like
what we talked about with the devops
quote earlier like at the end of the day
the reason why we're doing all this is
to deliver software more reliably and
more often right so if we can focus on
that and constantly bring that back to
the focus i find that cuts through a lot
of that tension
all right
so some takeaways
from this hopefully you choose a
migrations based approach you source
control your database auto auto deploy
those source control migrations
and some tools that you can use as well
as well as some of the gotchas that
you're going to run into both technical
and then process and people
organizational-wise as well
those are some things to take away
from this talk
so you can do this it's not a question
of can you do this because you have all
the tools at your disposal to do this
it's really a question of want to not
can it's does your organization actually
want to do this
so we've got some links here
uh so a link to the github with a
project that we showed earlier um it's
just again github.com my first last name
database devops so regates got some good
blogs on database devops as well as well
as the link to the state of database
devops survey that we talked about
earlier
and then here's a youtube video that's
really good with jeffrey palermo and
paul stovall talking about database
devops
so with that any questions yeah
what happens when things go wrong
for instance
if you show with the right way the
creativity statement if you've had
multiple create tables for some reason
let's say you can have an extension like
crypto installed yep
yeah so the question was what happens
when things go wrong like if say you've
got multiple create table statements and
you know uh one of them might rely on an
extension that's not installed um so
tools like flyway uh and you can
configure this as well will run each
script in a transaction so it'll either
do the whole thing or not so depending
on
uh
you know how you want to group things to
you can say like hey every you can
either say group things like hey all the
pending migrations run all of them in a
transaction so either they all succeed
or they all fail or you can say like
break things out and say each migration
is their own isolated transaction
now go ahead
you definitely can get into situations
where
um
you might have to
uh
change the schema history table
depending on what happened so you might
have to like say you get all the way you
deploy it out and you get all the way to
production everything succeeded um but
then you know production failed for
whatever reason let's say that script
was just like a poison pill script that
could never complete uh you might have
to like mark that script as
as either it's been executed and then
just kind of ignore it or like clean up
your lower environments to delete that
script out of source control so you can
absolutely get into weird situations
like that um depending on what's going
on
yeah
yes
yep
yep so the question was about or the
statement was more like any framework
code first doesn't really work great
when you have like stored procedures
functions views that that kind of thing
that's been my experience as well so any
framework is really good when you're
just using tables but if you have
additional ddl
in the mix
any framework doesn't work as well so
yeah flyway you just
deal with sql scripts at the end of the
day so you can still use any framework
because any framework has the option to
i can't remember what the switch is but
there's a switch on
the dotnet ef cli to output to sql
scripts instead of the c-sharp
migrations um so you could you still
still use any framework to generate some
of your
sql scripts um when you're dealing with
like tables and stuff like that
uh so that is an option as well
yep
all right come back come back yeah um
fly away is that all just pure sql
scripts if you want to manage static
data
basically you've got to write your own
script managing
yep so the question was when you're
dealing with static data do i have to
write sql scripts or is there a more
structured way so you just write sql
scripts they don't have anything to my
knowledge that
um other than sql scripts
i saw the same first yep go for it so
going back to the decision between a
model-based approach and a migration
base of course right
more about that because for example
thinking about this migration right we
have seen the demo with three of them
but obviously as time goes by and
different developers are contributing to
that due to this build validation you
can potentially have thousands of
migrations that have to be run and
that's not necessarily the shortest path
to the end state of the database yep
and on top of that for example the fact
that you cannot roll back to a
controlled state or whatever it is you
know we have consequence of using that i
mean migration based approach because if
you were using a model-based approach
you have a version of the previous
moment right
so so the point of not using a
model-based approach is it more based on
the fact that the tools that we have
today are not mature enough or is it a
fundamental pain that should be avoided
okay uh so there's
a few questions in there so it's really
about like model-based approach
migration-based approach talk more about
some of the issues there um you touched
on one of the drawbacks of migrations
which is like you know eventually you
just keep accumulating accumulating
scripts because they're immutable you
don't really
uh you can't really change the version
migrations
uh after the fact uh so you can uh when
that gets kind of unruly over time you
can flatten those out and rebate
re-baseline uh and a lot of tools like
flyway you can do that as well so once
you get to like okay you know it's been
got thousands of migrations here
whatever your tripping point is
you can re-baseline and flatten those
out and get rid of those migrations so
that's one way to avoid that
your other question was around
uh you know model-based approach like is
one of the challenges with it like the
tools aren't mature enough
um
i mean some of those tools like backpack
sql source control those have been
around for a while
i'm just like
i i i'm a developer i like having
control right so model-based approaches
you lose a lot of that control like
sometimes they have hooks that you can
hook into things but really i want that
control and like migrations give me that
control and i'm not going to get
surprised by what it does because it's
going to run the exact same migrations
everywhere so that's kind of why i lean
towards migrations over model based
approach
good all right yeah
you remembered your question perfect
um
yeah so the question was about uh
ordering matters uh so do you deploy
your application and then run your
migrations or run migrations and then
deploy your application
uh so i
so this is where things get a little
tricky so i i like to run my migrations
first and then run uh deploy my
application and i want to make sure that
my application can
handle like n minus one versions of the
database
so like i don't do destructive changes
like column renames for instance uh you
know in that situation i might add a new
column migrate the data over and then
re-point everything over and then you
know drop the column in a future
migration after the application's been
moved
that's obviously a lot more work and
it's also contextual right like say you
have an application that's just internal
facing you know it's only eight to five
uh there's an issue maybe you are okay
being down for you know 30 seconds or
whatever the case may be after hours so
again it's kind of contextual but if
you're in a 24 7 environment like most
of us are now
uh that's not really an option so that's
why i like having my applications being
able to support
previous versions of the database so
it's something i have to constantly keep
in mind
correct so yeah so if the database
migration fails then the new version of
the application doesn't go out but
that's also where things get tricky
right like if you separate into separate
repos
things get a lot trickier because
usually you're not pointed at the same
pipeline when you have separate repos
and there's just a lot more coordination
that you have to do so that's also why i
like to keep those things integrated
because ultimately they are tightly
coupled at the end of the day
some integration tests
environment and just
yeah so the question is about how do i
you know spin up essentially a
production like database on the fly um
more or less is that your question um
so that's where i really like tools like
docker so um
i can just you know i don't actually i
think i do have postgres installed but
like i'm sure i don't have the exact
version that i just used and the fireway
demo i like spinning up docker applying
migrations and with flyway like i've
done things like
have it look in additional folders uh
for local development so
you can tell it hey go look in this
folder and apply the migrations over
here so if you have like a test data
sample that you want to use
um i've done things like that before or
like you know before my integration test
like in a
so i've traditionally used c-sharp
x-unit like a class picture or something
like that that kind of runs before all
the tests to set up the data how i want
so i've done things like that as well
but yeah that's like
a perfect use case for docker where you
can spin things up throw it away when
you're done all that kind of stuff
yep
yep and
you know
it's not perfect though because like uh
you know let's say you've got
uh you know hundreds of gigabytes of
data in your production system
uh you probably aren't going to be able
to replicate that locally so figuring
out what that subset of data the
scenarios that make sense for you
and doing sanitization like all that
kind of stuff that's where a lot of that
stuff
comes in i saw a question yeah that's
exactly what i was gonna ask what a
future by database is it a real test
yeah so
uh
like anything like you know if we're
thinking about like the testing pyramid
right and i know there's testing diamond
testing trophy all that stuff now but uh
like you know unit tests give you the
most the least amount of confidence
integration tests give you more and and
give you more right so like i view that
similarly so
you know maybe my uh docker
docker databases are more like uh unit
tests where like they give me the least
amount of confidence and then i might
have
like some more end-to-end tests that are
actually running like smoke tests as i
deployed to dev test and production
caring about caring about like the
scenarios that i'm worried about
production gets a little iffy with smoke
testing because you probably don't want
to write data unless you've accounted
that for your systems
um
but yeah so i think finding that subset
of data that makes sense uh there's also
various tools out there like i know red
gate makes like sql clone for sql server
where
you can basically
take an entire database more or less and
clone it but it just does like deltas so
it doesn't copy the whole 100 gigabytes
it just i think by default it's like 100
megabytes or something and then just
does deltas
so that's another option as well but
again that's kind of how i look at it as
uh it's kind of like the testing pyramid
any other questions or anything somebody
wants me to do a live demo of
once going twice
all right thanks everybody